how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
mcu there are a lot of disney plus
marvel shows coming up but perhaps the
one that we know the least amount about
is
moon knight we have a trailer for the
one division series we also got tiny
little teasers for the falcon and the
winter soldier and the loki series as
well
we know actually quite a bit about the
hawkeye series and now we have our
official she-hulk slash jennifer walters
and not to mention we know who the
directors for the miss marvel series are
going to be
and we know a lot about some supporting
characters as well but when it comes to
moon knight
we've never really had any information
at all that is
until now we have some casting news that
reveals some of the main characters of
the moon knight series
a rumor of who could have already been
cast as moon knight himself
and we also have a little bit of an idea
of how it could connect to the one
division series and
also set up marvel's monster verse
setting up the midnight suns
and i'm going to be breaking down all of
this in this video but first if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu news
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway which is a scarlet witch funko
pop
so let's start off with the new
characters revealed by the latest
casting calls for
moon knight so this report is coming
from the direct and they say that they
have
exclusively learned that marvel studios
is casting for two main roles
for their moon knight series they say
their sources tell them that one of the
characters they're casting for
is john paul duchamp aka frenchy
who in the comics is the best friend of
mark spector aka
moon knight the casting call description
for the character reads as follows
a 20 to 40 year old white male a
stereotypical
good looking overly enthusiastic less
intelligent than average but still
lovable the actor must be fluent in
french
the second role is for a character who
is likely marlene
allaron a love interest of mark spector
the description for this character reads
20 to 35 years old all ethnicities
female
a manipulative operative in a secret
organization
capable of going from cool and tough to
warm
and friendly in a heartbeat now the fact
that the first character description
says it's looking for an actor that must
speak french is a dead giveaway that
this is the casting call for frenchie
frenchie is mark's best friend even
before he became moon knight and in some
cases he even does help moonlight out
with some of his missions
but something that's kind of interesting
about the character description
says less intelligent than average this
doesn't necessarily fit frenchie from
the comics he's not a dumb person
however something that we know about
moon knight is that he battles mental
illness and it's been said that this
disney plus show is going to dive into
and explore that it's being described as
a much more
darker project than we've seen from
marvel yet which isn't really that
surprising the one division trailer was
pretty bonkers and we know that the next
saga is going to be pretty different
than the first so the fact that mark
spectre is going to battle
mental illness and they're going to
explore a rather dark side in this show
means that they could want a character
for comedic purposes
and this could be where frenchie comes
in as a less intelligent than
average person this character could
offset the seriousness of mark specter
adding a much needed comedic relief as
for the character marlene goes she was
mark spector's love interest and she did
assist mark and frenchie on several
missions
now as far as the actual casting of mark
spector himself
we have had a lot of rumors going around
there was talks of keanu reeves daniel
radcliffe
and now we have a new one to throw into
the mix from a leaker who has been right
about many many things in the past but
still take it with a grain of salt
because of course it's not confirmed yet
supposed twitter account of roger
wardell the same person who leaked all
of the accurate things about avengers
in-game months before they came out
recently tweeted yesterday gabriel
mocked met with marvel studios earlier
this year about the role of mark spector
official moon knight casting
announcement was originally scheduled
for october but it might be delayed till
the end of 2020 which if this tweet is
real that would make a lot of sense to
delay it until 2020 because
moon knight is most likely going to be
pushed back much like the entirety of
phase four
and if this is real gabriel mocked might
be playing mark spectre in the mcu
now something to keep in mind though is
that marvel studios meets with many
different people for many different
roles
and they often time meet with actors to
see if they're a good fit for the role
and a lot of the times it doesn't work
out but marvel studios continues to meet
with them until they find something that
does fit this is what happened with jake
gyllenhaal
and mysterio marvel studios met with
jake about many different movies and
many different roles to play until they
finally decided that mysterio was a
perfect fit
and of course it was they're doing the
same with keanu reeves and apparently
they're doing the same for gabriel macht
and as far as casting goes for moon
knight that wouldn't actually be a bad
pick
gabriel could play the role of one of
mark spector's personas a millionaire
but he could also play the role of
somebody who struggles with a mental
illness and
also physically beats people now the
casting is going to be pretty important
because
moon knight isn't just going to appear
in his series there's most likely going
to be some major connections to
sort of a new universe inside the mcu
that is going to be developed and that
is the monster verse now the monster
verse is going to consist of a little
bit of witchcraft and a little bit of
well monsters with one division coming
setting up witchcraft inside of the mcu
and blade eventually coming down the
road as well
setting up vampires marvel studios is
now exploring an entirely different
genre from the original infinity saga
one that involves witchcraft demons and
vampires
and eventually there's going to have to
be a group form that's going to go
against all of these different
new evil forces and that's where the
midnight suns come in
now the midnight suns team in the comics
is actually very interesting if you
consider the characters that are coming
to the marvel cinematic universe
and another universe as well i'm talking
about sony's universe because morbius is
on the team in the comics doctor strange
is also on the team
and we know that multiverse of madness
is going to further explore witchcraft
and
demons making him a perfect fit for the
team also on the team is elsa bloodstone
who is also reportedly supposed to be in
multiverse of madness
blade is on the team and of course moon
knight is on the team as well
but something that is really interesting
and very exciting to think about
is the fact that ghost rider is the one
who originally forms the midnight suns
in the comics
and given all the proof that we have
that the monster verse is going to come
that may mean that we could see ghost
writer in the mcu
now who could the midnight suns
including moon knight be possibly
fighting against
well it seems like there's a ton of
evidence suggesting that mephisto is
going to be in the mcu
sooner rather than later in fact many
people think that mephisto is behind
what is going on in the wanda vision
series
and this could be where everything kind
of starts to connect in the comics the
midnight suns help doctor strange fight
off mephisto's forces
now doctor strange has had several
run-ins with mephisto
including one where he actually goes to
the hell dimension with
dr doom doctor doom and doctor strange
fight mephisto and are fortunate enough
to be able to escape so if one division
is going to set up mephisto which it
sure does look like it's going to do
then that'll definitely bleed into
doctor strange because we know that one
division is going to lead
right up to the events of multiverse of
madness and this is where everything can
kind of collide
doctor strange with the midnight suns
and with the scarlet witch
and from there on out the monster verse
could be formed inside of the mcu with
blade being one of the movies coming up
after
so for those who say that marvel studios
kind of does the same thing over and
over again
there's definitely going to be a
different tone in the mcu coming up soon
with all of these different characters
and proof of that was in the wanda
vision trailer that we got which was
unlike anything that we've seen in the
mcu so far so be sure to let me know
what you think about this moon knight
news do you think gabriel mock would be
a good
mark spectre and are you excited for a
monsterverse to be coming to the mcu let
me know all of your thoughts and
feelings in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news
also a reminder that i'm doing more
funko pop giveaways on my instagram and
twitter so be sure to follow me on there
to enter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof